hi before screen junkies movie fights
what in the world
welcome to hashtag movie fights live
this is movie fights we are live today
and I also want to ask where my owls at
hoot hoot hello
hashtag owl nation we've got an awesome
fight happy Valentine's Day we're going
to delve into the the wonderful
beautiful lovely world of rom-coms and
oh there's just so much love in the air
let's meet this panel that is just
overflowing with effervescent love and
hearts and and adorable emojis first up
uh-oh I'd like to welcome him back
Hector we haven't seen you in a while
Yeltsin DC Daily hyper RPG and all over
the Internet Hector Navarro thank you so
much for having me hashtag L nation what
is that oh it's just a thing it's just a
silly thing yeah well like it's not bad
it's not offensive I could say it oh
yeah you could say it you could say
hashtag y'all nation whoo yeah I like to
refer to like a large like a good
portion of our movie fights fans has owl
nation and sure yeah Lana and I were
just both wearing our related apparel
one day and we were like oh yeah let's
make that a thing and we haven't stopped
saying at least I haven't great to have
you Hector nice man oh um I'd like to
welcome back she's become a good friend
of the show and you know are from all
over the world wide web trisha
hershberger what's going on
Valentine's Day Oh happy Valentine's to
you Parks and Rec fans happy galentine's
yesterday you've got some pretty cool
earrings for Valentine's Day I don't
know if you could see them but they are
playbills for rent
the best you well my husband got them
for me for Valentine's Day so I don't
five hundred twenty five thousand six
hundred dollars dollars nice last but
not least we have a special guest in the
house you nor is the voice of Cora on
legends of Cora welcome Janet Barney oh
[Applause]
yeah you created a finger emoji Janet
you're part of a new series called
voyage to the stars that were pretty
excited to hear about can you tell us a
little bit about it yeah so it is a
partially scripted partially improvised
podcast which is not something that I
personally have ever heard of before for
me this is a new format both as a fan
and as a participant and we are miss
sort of a misfit group that is traveling
the galaxy through a wormhole I play a
sarcastic AI who may or may not be
interested in murdering the humans that
are on board
can I hear your can I hear your AI voice
I sort of based it on the weird informal
yet formal kind of mean and cold I think
you said can I hear with a voice sound
I'm sorry I'm just not understanding you
please call again
bye wow I don't know if that's logic or
snark wow that sounds pretty good that's
don't you feel that way with customer
service say a robot like that sorry I
they want you to believe yes so it's
like if data was a jerk well that's
super awesome and that sounds like just
a fun scenario to kind of sell the rest
of the cast amazing Felicia Day please
yes Colton Dunn and Steve Berg just
amazing oh yeah I know Colton from The
Upright Citizens Brigade forces on
superstore yeah awesome Janet thank you
so much for being here yeah you deciding
these movie fights are going to be
myself and the dance let's take a look
at the Dan cam what up Dan Moreau on the
facts Dan thank you for being in this
seat I couldn't be here last week but
you how was that it was awesome it's
like I said it's my first time judging
new formula movie fights yeah it was fun
thank you for letting me fill in for you
oh of course anytime that was super
great oh and speaking of logic you got
some Spock on your shirt [ __ ] yeah
massage massage yes nice and she is I
think she's uh she's social medias best
friend everybody's best friend Danielle
Radford Danielle you I break down what's
going on with you over there yes so the
way this works is that in the case of a
tie we have a tiebreaker poll and there
are lots of great polls that are on
Twitter but the only one that counts for
our purposes is the one that is on
YouTube if you have any questions about
how that works
head to the description below ask one of
us in the chat we will be sure to help
you out with the poll stuff does not
start going up until everyone has given
their their initial arguments we want
this to be about the debates
additionally come hang out with us over
our movie fights live because I'll be
checking for any kind of interesting
contacts funding memes all of those
things and if I like your comment I
might give you a shout out during the
show oh I want a shout-out from Danielle
make some comments you guys so again how
it works the first person to four points
will walk out of here the Victoire after
the first three rounds then we'll go to
the speed round and the top two players
will move on to the speed round
then it's anybody's ballgame because
someone can be down 3-0 but make a
furious comeback and take it four to
three who knows anything can happen you
guys ready for the fun yeah GTE dropped
that package
[Music]
yeah pretty good on brandcast show
yes thank you for yes Hector noted as we
were sitting here watching it that is
all the times they fight in movie yeah
and those are all the fights we compiled
everything of the fights alright
question number one as we establish
lumps in the air it is Valentine's Day
in honor of Valentine's Day what is the
worst romantic drama or rom-com of all
time
ooh boy what is the biggest stinker rule
in the rom-com department and we're
going to start with player number one
for question number one Hector okay I'm
gonna come out of the gate strong I'm
picking sixteen Candles because it is
racist and sexist and homophobic and
it's harmful and sinister it celebrates
date rape the two main male characters
talk about violating a girl who's passed
out from being drunk as if there's
nothing wrong with that the geek Anthony
Michael Hall also cannot take a hit with
Sam and he's made to be a nice guy
here's a hint he is not every time long
Duk dong is on screen it's a company
with a gong he crashes the car just
because he's Asian this led to an entire
generation of asian-americans bullying
in the back half of the 80s and into the
90s they would get called Oh sexy
girlfriend constantly yelled at them
Japanese actor Getty Watanabe talked
about being naive when he made the film
he thought he was just making people
laugh and it's it is a movie that so
many people have gone back and actually
revisited and reflected on and it's
awful Sam and her female friend also
there's a sentence where her female
friend Randy they're apparently appalled
at the idea of dating a black guy one of
the jocks says Sam might be quote
[ __ ] because she's looking at Jake
in class Molly Ringwald ultimately comes
around to believe that it's okay to
continue to appreciate films that didn't
seem so irresponsible upon first feeling
but that they should be re-evaluated she
said she was embarrassed that it took
her that long to fully comprehend the
scene late in sixteen Candles when the
dreamboat Jake essentially trades his
drunk girlfriend Caroline and she's like
passed out drunk in the car to the geek
to satisfy the late the latter's of
sexual urges in return for Samantha's
underwear the geek takes Polaroids with
Caroline to have proof of his conquest
when she wakes up in the morning and she
doesn't know what's happening he asks if
she enjoyed it and she
either of them remember much and she
says you know I have this weird feeling
I did Molly Ringwald said she had to
have a feeling about it rather than a
thought because thoughts are things that
we have when we're conscious and she
wasn't when she reflects on John Hughes
his career she says his earlier writing
could also be considered racist
misogynistic and at times homophobic the
words [ __ ] and [ __ ] are tossed around
with abandon the character of long Duk
dong in sixteen Candles is a grotesque
stereotype there's barely a person of
color to be found in the films and no
characters are openly gay Ringwald was
revaluing these movies 30 years after
she did them because her own daughter
was roughly around the same age that she
was when John Hughes made her his screen
Muse and it was a moment to where Molly
Ringwald's mom had to step in and be
like you need to change this line
because at one point they were gonna
have in the film that Molly Ringwald's
dad was just gonna notice that her
underwear was missing and Molly's mom
had to be like why would her dad know
that so they changed the line instead to
have the father say you know remember
you wear the pants in the relationship
as opposed to some other weird creepy
comment and John Hughes had to be like
well I didn't mean it like that
so the mom had to step in and do that
the problem is is that this movie is
considered a classic it is streaming on
Netflix currently it led to John
Hughes's really successful career so my
issue is is that because people love it
so much and it is considered what it is
so highly regarded it is hugely
problematic it is disgusting it it it
idolizes the wrong way to treat women
the wrong way for women to think about
themselves in sexuality and it's such a
bummer because it is one of the few
movies especially about generations
starring a young woman and it's
completely tainted and we should throw
it away and cancel it and all that other
good stuff it's the worst
well my childhoods been ruined
[Applause]
definitely problematic is it the worst
rom-com of all time we will suss that
out
trisha hershberger okay I mean I just I
can I give a standing out and I remember
that that awesome opening argument that
was great yeah when while that was great
and I believe everything that Hector
said I do not think sixteen Candles is
the worst rom-com of all time because
I'm gonna compare it to the hottie and
the Nottie
naughty like oh you've been so naughty
this is the word hottie replaced with an
N this is a Paris Hilton rom-com the
whole plot of this film is that Paris
helps her unattractive best friend Paris
is the hot one her friend is the naughty
she helps her unattractive best friend
find love by refusing the same man over
and over and over and over herself until
he's like oh you know what your friend
is kind of attractive that's the whole
point of this movie it is offensive it
the plot is absolutely atrocious and in
notthat reviews or anything by any means
but if we're gonna talk about the worst
movies of all times I feel like it's
appropriate to bring up the popular
consensus this film has a 1 point 9 out
of 10 on IMDB 5 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes it's it's pretty high up there
on Metacritic all-time lowest scoring
films I believe it's number 13 so it's
right up there with baby geniuses and
biodome amazing let you know the company
that we're in here if someone Awards for
being so bad Paris Hilton Wanda Razzie
for the golden Razzie award for worst
actress in a film they won Razzies for
two of them for worst on-screen couple
for both her and her best friend and the
love interest couple and they were
nominated for worst screenplay worst
picture and worst director so overall
I'm pretty sure everyone is in agreement
that the hottie and the Nottie is
absolutely worse and just to to leave
you with this I this is this was what
one critic said about the hottie and the
Nottie imagine the worst movie you've
ever seen got it now try to think of
something worse that something is this
movie wretched embarrassing and a waste
of the time and energy of everyone
involved the hottie and the Nottie
alright Trisha is not a fan of the
hottie and the Nottie Janet well first
of all let me get my notes together
clearly I've done the show before I know
that you need to have
an entire litany of reasons that
something it takes all good the callers
many different rounds many different
routes to an argument okay first of all
am i I'm just addressing my I'm just
addressing what I picked yeah I'm not
give us an opening statement telling yes
tell us what yours is and then we'll
open it up to everybody okay what I will
say is what could be wrong with taking a
a television show a reality television
competition show in its first very first
year and it was a tremendous success so
why would it be a bad idea to take the
winner and runner-up of the who is a
talented singer contest on a reality
show and turn that into a romantic
comedy movie between the two of them
because I'm sure that they can act and
I'm sure that they have chemistry and
I'm sure that it won't be hastily thrown
together and just sort of scrambled
where you just kind of take a little
piece of grease and a little piece of
like cocktail and a little piece of
sixteen Candles and a little piece of
the hottie and the Nottie it's possible
that came out afterwards you sort of
take a little potpourri of all of the
worst things about every other worst
movie so it managed to succeed in
throwing all of that stuff into one
clumsy stew of a movie and that movie is
called from Justin to Kelly and is just
an abomination by the picture we saw the
fashion was already an abomination if it
gets worse open it up you can fight it
out everybody both of those are very bad
movies they're bad movies to be sure for
sure but my main argument against both
of these movies is that nobody really
has seen them and I'm not worried about
a bunch of people continuing to see them
for example I'll give you an example
they're not super readily available to
like find I don't think from Justin to
Kelly or the hottie in the body are on
Netflix streaming anywhere and
video Google's it's really that's on the
very available but I think that the the
main takeaway here is that both of those
movies you know what you're getting into
like you were setting up jannat
beautifully it was a cash-in for sure
and I think from Justin to Kelly was
originally meant to be like a
direct-to-video release and in fact they
had planned to release it on DVD six
weeks after it was in theatres so a
bunch of theater chains got mad and
they're like we were not going to screen
it then it should be at least three
months and they're like okay okay and
then went back on it the movie comes out
bombs they still put it out six weeks
after to put it immediately on DVD to
cash in on that American Idol fervor
Kelly Clarkson knew that it was gonna be
bad but she signed a contract it's all
contractually obligated when you get to
the hottie and the Nottie
one of the producing partners was paris
hilton entertainment again you know what
you're getting into these are bad movies
but Kelly they're harmless from Justin
to Kelly made four point nine million
dollars to hottie and the Nottie made
one-and-a-half million worldwide and
each of those at least they kind of know
their audience from Justin to Kelly was
nominated for two Teen Choice Awards for
breakout stars and Choice chemistry now
we might disagree with that but their
demographic is the Teen Choice Awards
and they were like yeah sure we'll eat
that up the hottie and the Nottie one
critic John Anderson of Newsday said
well while he was panning it he was also
saying he concluded look it's no worse
in many ways and a lot of teen centric
comedies which generally appealed to
their audience through cruelty and
vulgarity and I will point to one of
those teen comedies being sixteen
Candles again my main argument is that
it's considered a classic and people
continue to share it with their kids
hopefully followed up with a
conversation like Molly Ringwald Leone
star did so again but at least
potentially it could spawn a
conversation the question was what's the
biggest letdown romantic film of all
time or the biggest disappointment then
I would say that your sole argument that
you have here holds weight but it's not
it's what's the worst inherently the
worst romantic comedy or drama of all
time so when we're talking about
something that's a horrible movie I
don't think you can say something that
has Molly Ringwald's amazing performance
in it that has John Hughes writing and
directing in it like these are talented
people that make beautiful things and as
you even mention a lot of critics still
hold sixteen Candles to be this
momentous moment in filmmaking so when
we're talking about the worst film to me
that's something with no redeemable
whatsoever which has to be the hottie
and the Nottie everything about it is
absolutely awful and from justin kelly i
agree with you super badly oh yeah
really really bad not as bad as the
hottie and the Nottie
and just to drop some more numbers on
that hottie in the naughty is number 13
on metacritic s-- worst ever movies list
from Justin to Kelly is number 68 so way
better ranked than the hottie and the
Nottie and I would say from Justin Kelly
as someone who was an American Idol
season 1 fan it's enjoyably bad and if
you like Justin and Kelly that's the
official Ramsay said the official Razzie
movie guide lists from Justin to Kelly
as one of them 100 most enjoyably bad
movies ever made yeah I can't appreciate
that sometimes yeah you like those two
people singing uh-huh you're going to
get more of them singing and you're
going to get those two people which is
something redeemable about the film I'm
going on that there's got to be nothing
redeemable for the soldiers ever nesting
Lincoln from step by step is in the
movie she plays Donati
she was also al Lambert on set by saying
she's fantastic
she's great she pops up a lot of other
places and that's where you can find her
so if this film never existed or cease
to exist no one would be sad because if
Christine Lakin is the number one thing
about it you can find her many wonderful
other places I'm gonna quickly say and I
don't disagree with anything you said
I'm on the fence
I fought about the hottie and the Nottie
I'll be very honest with you if that
pushes you into the winner's circle I
understand to be honest have you guys
and listen I don't know but like I
actually didn't go with what a lot of
other people said okay I didn't go flat
facts and figures a lot of what was the
worst movie I felt that my choice was
from the heart okay they came from the
inside of me and my brain and heart and
I I didn't I I mean I know that was very
poorly review but I didn't come with
with with information from other people
from outside sources for me this is my
worst personal movie and you can't I
mean you can't vote me out of that if I
feel worse and that's my personal truth
yeah
then that's my personal truth I
that Hector's personal truths that he
believes that six years we're gonna go
around and get any final thoughts final
sentence a Hector please let's just -
I've only seen pieces of sixteen Candles
here and there up to last night
where when I sent in sixteen Candles as
the worst pick because I knew of some of
the sinister things that were in the
film Irie wash it and wash it all the
way through last night for the
essentially the first time and it broke
my heart and there were things in there
that were so unbelievably racist and
sexist and and harmful especially the
way that the dudes talk about a girl
who's passed out these things that I was
seeing is this was a huge issue that the
United States and masculinity have not
dealt with and the movie doesn't even
try to deal when a that stuff and they
make the hunk out to be this hunky guy
when he's just it's just like the worst
type of stuff so my heart was broken I
was sick to my stomach at certain lines
at certain little throwaway comments it
was a really really disappointing but I
think ultimately the most harmful and
bad and worst movie as opposed to the
other two which are bad movies all of
the room where you can get together with
your friends and have a good time and
drink and make fun of them but
ultimately you're not gonna walk away
and go man from Justin to Kelly was
super racist wasn't it yeah it
definitely was the hottie and the Nottie
talked about women in an awful way ya
know that happens with my movie so
that's why I think it's sourced thank
you Hector
Trisha talking about women in awful ways
exactly what the hottie and the Nottie
is about I mean she's got in this grew
tusks acne and she's so unattractive no
one will even look at her how could
someone possibly love her which is the
worst most harmful thing you can tell
women my argument is that the question
is the worst romantic drama or rom-com
of all time and for something to be the
worst of all time I think that means you
you cannot find one redeemable thing in
it if it's the worst it means it's the
worst in every category in directing in
writing in acting in cinematography and
makeup in wardrobe and all these things
that we appreciate about great cinema
and give awards for at the end of the
year
this is awful in every single one of
them and it's not even awful in every
one like the room where you can at least
enjoy it later it's so cringe-worthy and
offensive to
sit through it's a full-on hellish
punishment to sit through this film and
that's why I would say the hottie and
the Nottie is the absolute worst
romantic comedy of all time Thank You
Tricia Janet okay closing thoughts first
of all though here's the problem Hector
you've done such an amazing job about
arguing the significance of sixteen
Candles that we can't just toss it to
the side this is whether or not it's
it's a successful and remains a
successful romantic comedy is absolutely
that question but it's a conversation
it's a conversation starter it's the
opportunity for parents to talk to their
kids for it's an opportunity I would
take a class that you taught about John
Hughes films and what's wrong with them
and it would give me an understanding of
what was going on in a totally different
era for that I don't want that to
disappear I feel that there actually is
a reason that that phone should be
around I can't say the same thing about
yours but at least there is still this
sort of you guys both leaned into the
kind of like this is why this is
offensive and I think it's important for
us to talk about those things and if we
push them to the side and have them
never exist we're never gonna change it
we're never gonna understand what's
wrong from Dustin Kelly there's nothing
like that there's nothing like that so
this is what what this movie is is just
the very worst edit an attempt at just
like a sad like attempt like oh this is
why romantic comedies are and it just
fails on every level I don't think that
it is enjoyable just because it's a fun
bad thing to watch I find it totally
unwatchable and I also I can't give you
the absolute worst foam for the hottie
in Noddy because it still feels like
Paris Hilton is winning something if you
say her movie is the very worst number
one
if for that award that cries she does
not deserve anything even if it's the
best of the worst time all right Wow
well played all dan where are we in the
fact zone just a couple things yeah
Canio goal of the Miami Herald was the
critic that have provided the scathing
review of the hottie and the Nottie that
was used in the argument from Justin to
Kelly was released in 2003 the honey and
I use released in 2008 but you kind of
get into a time warp with movies that
bad
and if you are lucky enough to be an
Amazon Prime subscription you can watch
the hottie and the Nottie right now
thanks dad everybody is clicking away
this was a really eye-opening argument
and I knew I knew some of what you were
saying Hector regarding sixteen Candles
but like it was it really really
resonated but it coming down to the
spirit of the question and thinking
about okay what is problematic versus
what is just the overall worst movie it
was there are a lot of factors at play
Janet you but that was a great closing
together yeah you did pull it together I
mean who needs pages of notes you're off
the cuff yeah you I really do not in
retrospect just hate that movie more now
and Tricia I thought you had a great
comprehensive breakdown on why haughty
and naughty was problematic and just a
poorly done poorly executed film and at
the end of the day Trish's argument kind
of rose above for me just as far as in
so many aspects because they dig a
little bit Molly Ringwald's performance
is triumphant
I thought we you had some great points
Janet Patricia yeah had the most going
for as far as just being a bad film in
every category tough choice but Tricia
gets it for me can disagree I hand this
agree I can't believe I won something
with the hottie in the well
yes I agree a very difficult choice and
I stuck a couple pieces at the chat and
some people were comparing this round to
around the I fought at comic-con against
Kevin Smith about a movie that should be
erased forever and I picked jaws too and
he picked triumph of the will and that's
hard to fight against because obviously
yes but Janet actually particularly in
the closing there said the exact
argument that I thought of in the shower
two weeks later and that's my head which
was and I thought it was really
compelling not just because I wish that
I'd made it but the idea of yes you can
notice something is horrible but in
another way it can serve a function as a
conversation starter as a spotlight as
something that can bring more awareness
to how things have changed and I think
that undermined a lot of Hector's
fundamental arguments by the way I
watched sixteen Candles and pretty and
pink recently for the first time and I
agree 100% like those movie sure is they
have some very things that do not hold
up and it really shouldn't be in society
but particularly in light of today
however I thought Janet really artfully
sort of made a distinction there
and so in deciding which one I was gonna
vote for I actually I I thought it's
pretty close for me between Tricia and
Janet and I actually kind of like the
creativity of the argument was like even
though it's the worst do I give the
Paris Hilton the win I thought that was
argument so an argument that closed I'm
actually gonna go with Janet all right
so one for Janet one for Tricia Danielle
what does the internet poll have to say
all right as of right now this second we
have with 45% of the vote the hottie and
the Nottie we have sixteen Candles of
twenty nine percent and from Justin to
Kelly to twenty four percent that last
minute rally argument and that wake
counter really went over the chat from
what I was saying so some of the other
ones that people had mentioned biodome
grease - how dare you correct
Geely what women want Valentine's Day
all really good and this one in
particular so kookiness monster said
let's be clear Valentine's Day is the
worst romantic comedy of all time it's a
hodgepodge of famous people who were
tricked into making something that
resembles a movie alright so going into
round number two it's one for Tricia
Janet and Hector looking to get on the
board all right here we go doesn't get
any easier also gonna be no okay this is
impossible
we're taking a slight detour here round
two since we have an animation star at
the table we thought we'd do a TV
question animation TV centric so with
that being said let's ask a big one
what's the best animated series of all
time what yeah how can we possibly we're
gonna decide that here today we are we
will finally once and for all decide
that and we're gonna start question
number two player number two Trisha what
do you got I feel like the only possible
answer this question it's Batman the
Animated Series I mean it even has the
animated series in the name for anyone
who's questioning but seriously yes it
is animated series is so beautifully
done in just about every single possible
wave they're writing by Paul Dini the
beautiful Gothic architecture that
composes the city of Gotham which feels
like a character in and of itself the
dual tonality where we get so much
nuance in our villains our Joker we get
to meet other Batman characters like
two-faced and we get introduced to
Harley Quinn for the very first time I
mean just everything about this series
is so perfectly done and perfectly hits
for both an adult audience as well as
for kids I mean to make a Joker that's
satisfying to the DC Comics
audience the adult audience and still
light enough for children to watch
without getting horrific nightmares is a
piece of art in and of itself this
series did it beautifully and it set up
DC for what we know of Batman
this did it this this gave us mark
Hamill's joker this gave us like I said
Harley Quinn and it gave us when people
think Batman now in the Batman universe
a lot of what they draw from is this
series so Batman the Animated Series
alright
Tricia comes strong with Batman Janet
well first of all I love them and I have
no problem it is a great series it's a
character that has been very explored
I'm not saying that they're not doing it
but the better or the best you know with
this series you're gonna a lot of
choices when you're looking for Man Man
I'm not sure that that really is you
know I don't know that that here's what
when you said the only possible answer
for this question is Batman the Animated
Series I was like goodbye because that's
just not true I understand that we're
doing a debate but that offends me as a
person who was had the absolute
privilege and joy oh boy seen a female
hero on a show that is a show that is
going to be and and I and I truly am
saying this as a fan I'm not saying this
as a person who got to work on it also
there are a lot of shows that people get
to work on that are not fun experiences
or that they don't believe in after the
fact this is something that I am so so
honored to have been a part of even if I
weren't I would still say that this is
the best series I think it pulls from so
many different philosophies and it has
you know the martial arts element and it
has the the it has so much humor so much
graceful exciting action it has a hero
who like your friend is very complicated
it's not perfect is struggling through
something has lessons to learn has to
pick herself up has to learn how to ask
for help from others has to face
villains who again like you said are
very nuanced I mean these guys are
brand-new never before seen totally
created you know by Mike Ryan amazing
creators but they are they are villains
that they make sense and that's what
makes the story time so compelling I
understand that you're gonna be going
back to series one and I totally
appreciate that and I don't disagree I
just think that for me and my experience
in my age and my gender and all that
kind of stuff that again from the heart
this one is was more meaningful for me
personally from the PT s that that Cora
experiences I don't like adding the D
because I don't think it's a disorder I
think it's an experience and the way
that she gets through that to the
relationship that ends the series with
Asami where I still have people coming
up to me in tears saying this is how I
came out to my parents I will never be
able to say that there is any series
better than The Legend of Korra there
may be one as good Hector but there is
nothing better all right Janet with a
stirring opening argument for a legend
of korra Hector I can't believe I do
this to myself I hope you know so Trisha
great pick
good enough take score I would have
picked yours absolutely my pick is
Avatar The Last Airbender and I'm gonna
you know what I have notes some great
not so much I do this from the heart
okay because that's how much this show
means to me as well perspective there
was nothing on the air like avatar
before avatar and I think that so many
shows not just a legend of korra which
was a beautiful follow up and the job
that legend core had which was such an
impossible task which was to exceed what
avatar did and in many ways it did and
personally speaking personally I prefer
Korra but I have to say that avatar the
last airbender is overall a better more
impactful show in the history that it
made in animation and it's not just
Korra that it was obviously influenced
by and kind of followed it up but but
animation after this was allowed to be
more serialized even going back to
batman the animated series fantastic
show but that first batman run was very
episodic and it wasn't until later shows
you know avatar korra have the advantage
that batman did not which is you know 10
20 15 years later were able to delve
into this beautifully moving stories
avatar the last emperor was able to tell
kids about things like genocide and and
all of these horrific concepts and
explained to them in a way that they
could understand and it was still this
immensely moving and gorgeously detailed
show nothing on the air was like it
before Avatar The Last Airbender Korra
was more inward and personal and that's
what I
love about it but for me avatar is more
simple and is more concise it is more is
as impossible Janet's looking at me it's
car right this is so hard why did I do
this with myself but avatar is just
something that to me is a little bit
more I don't wanna say mainstream but
just accessible for many many different
ages whereas core I think it's at a
specific agent Gaad it hits so so well
but without avatar the last imminent we
would not have the quality of shows
across the board on every network that
we have today it was also this beautiful
combination the first combination really
of American storytelling with this
gorgeous Asian overseas art that
beautifully mix that together and Korra
did not drop the ball by any means but
the ball was put in play by avatar the
last airbender so I have to give it all
right so let's all gang up on Batman
first of all we also counting the new
Batman adventures that's part of it just
you're gonna say no okay that helps my
argument so Batman the Animated Series
if it was as good as it was I don't
think that the designs would have been
as drastically changed when we went to
the new Batman adventures Superman the
animated series Justice League Batman
Beyond and Beyond and they did change
with Superman and they sort of stayed
that way up until now there's gonna be a
new direct-to-video movie coming out
called Justice League versus the fatal
five that is still using those designs
versus the more clunky bulky big suited
early 90s Batman the Animated Series
look and some of the animation if you go
back and look at it the writing is still
top-notch yes but some of that animation
is clunky it's not as great I'm gonna
refer to my notes there was an animation
historian Charles Solomon who said that
he was commenting to dark art déco
influenced backgrounds tended to eclipse
the stiff animation and pedestrian
storytelling and he concluded that the
series looked better in stills and it
did on screens for some of those early
episodes I agree look there was 85
episodes of that there was a lot of
filler we got him I have a whole list of
random Batman episodes that I can list
off right now you're not gonna know what
they are but every episode of avatar and
Korra were essential viewing you
couldn't skip any of those so we just
have the unfair advantage Janet and I of
having a completely different animation
landscape they were working with
different parameters then Batman was
great but and it broke a lot of ground
but it was always improved upon even
with the writing even with superhero
storytelling and episode of Young
Justice is able to balance more
characters more character growth which
Batman really wasn't allowed to do at
that point because it was still that
episodic formula thing in 22 minutes in
Batman used to do it in like 10 minutes
or in 10 episodes rather so new like
newer superhero stuff has gotten even
tighter and also say this like Janet
said Batman was looking at the comics
for inspiration the comics whereas our
shows were completely from the ground up
animated shows at their core and so
that's why I think to harness a massive
amount of lore I would say that's an
argument for Batman the Animated Series
that it had so much source material it
had to be truthful to and depict within
an episodic series as you said and
having the challenge within an episodic
series to give a character as nuanced
and detailed as Harley Quinn that is
still to this day the best portrayal
we've seen of Harley and everything
she's dealing with you guys are talking
about dealing with huge issues and I
agree you guys are bringing audiences a
new way to talk about a lot of this
stuff that's gonna be very difficult for
them Batman the Animated Series let
people deal with mental illness it let
people figure out how they can take
their pain and either let it turn them
into a joker or a two-face or let it
turn them into a Batman let them use it
to become a hero Batman the Animated
Series dealt with very very heavy stuff
for kids as well so I think it's unfair
to write that off as just some comic
book kids show crime and the animated
series did that earlier and I would
argue that made it even harder
based on the landscape the Batman the
Animated Series was in to break that
kind of ground and pave that way for
future animated series this is it this
is the one that did it well I also want
to add in here I didn't mention before
Danny Elfman's incredible score for the
theme absolutely fantastic I already
mentioned the voice acting top-notch the
writing absolutely brilliant and again I
know you guys are kind of using it as
against Batman the animated series that
I've had so much comic source material
to draw from but
had diehard fans that needed that source
material to be respected and marketing
people that needed it to be marketed to
children to sell action figures and it
expertly did both of those at the exact
same time now I have notes here to argue
against your two series they feel really
awkward doing this I know the both
series are absolutely fantastic let me
say that I will say with The Legend of
Korra I wish that there was more dealt
with the non-benders versus benders and
kind of the realistic real world
conflict that that could make kind of
similar to like an x-men thing I feel
like in the in the early episodes we
start seeing some real arguments made
for the other side and then it kind of
goes off into like now I'm a crazy cult
leader and I disagree I think it was
great I thought it was great and I would
also say there were some moments when I
thought the comedy and the drama aspects
maybe didn't meld as well like we're
dealing with serious teen issues and
then we're fart bending you know like
back-to-back so but my guys called
teenager hood I'm being super nit picky
here we go this is a very good series
about me our time so those those are the
things I have to say if I have to make a
knock against Legend of Korra that's
absolutely what I would say you stop
right there before you talk man also was
able to ride the coattails of success of
Batman Elfman's Batman now sorry not
often Tim Burton's Batman 1980 1989 and
1992 Batman Returns that already proved
that you could do Batman in a more dark
gothic way that helped that show sort of
get greenlit but again going back to
avatar Korra was a done deal
Niccolo he was like please give us more
right in like please but avatar was like
this what's your pitch and it was a
completely new world Jen I would love to
hear a little bit more from the ground
yeah yeah sure I think that you guys
have made my job very simple and I think
it's probably because you are trying to
take it easy on me but the good news is
you're right to do so because I happened
I just happened to have had the
privilege again in the honour of having
been on the best animated series after
you said it yourself you said it for me
you said sure it the avatar broke ground
and then they exceeded you use those
words you said then like a bright X some
ways in some places seeded what they had
taken and brought to the table without
her I don't think that it was for a
specific age I think that's talking down
to the people who love the show who
aren't necessarily the age that might
have been the target audience for me
again the personal experience the
one-on-one of families who are watching
it with their children people who again
I just think that while I absolutely
love this
the first series loved it so much I
agree with you would it be possible for
court to exist without it but just
because link came before something
doesn't make it better
I agree Batman it can't and so that's
and I think culturally for us and for
what's going on right now Cora is the
one that really pushed through and broke
that glass ceiling and to me that's very
very important right now
this has been an emotional journey let's
move to final thoughts starting with
player number two trisha hershberger I'm
giving it to Batman the Animated Series
because it did have so many episodes
that ran for so long and it did it
beautifully all the time from Danny
Elfman's
Orchestra score to paul Dinis brilliant
nuanced writing and character creation
to the heart in every episode between
feeling the pain and understanding the
pain of these villains and how it
mirrors beautifully the pain of our hero
I mean you feel it every time Bruce
Wayne has to say goodbye to a lover and
what really could be his happily ever
after because his real calling is the
pain within him to help everyone else
and his real calling is for justice it
inspires us all to find our hero within
and to use maybe any trauma anything
that we've had happened to us in the
past that was hard to get through rise
above it and become a hero
again it's Paul Dean he's writing it's
Danny Elfman score it's the beautiful
animation that dark Gothic style and
what it did for the world and I will
also say as far as it won Primetime
Emmys at one Daytime Emmys this show has
moved so many people and made so much
ground for animated series to come after
it
thanks Trisha Janet III I think
everything you said was wonderful
everything you said checked off all the
boxes for me with Legend of Korra but
then they're just a few more boxes
that that show doesn't check off for me
so for me that that again you take
something that's groundbreaking and and
absolutely wonderful in its own right
and then you raise it up a couple more
notches in terms of for me again
personally emotional quality same kind
of situation where you're shown that you
can be a imperfect be an imperfect hero
in your own life you can you can
overcome tremendous obstacles you can
process post-traumatic stress and and
it's not just some throwaway thing I
disagree with you I don't think that
those concepts were sort of explored and
then thrown away for something fluffier
I don't feel that that's true of korah
at all I feel that that all of those
conflicts were very very well explored
and there's just no fat on the bone in
terms of those core episodes there tight
you again as Hector pointed out you
can't miss a single one because there's
something meaningful and and wonderful
and and and emotionally important in
each episode and then again it ends with
something that was for me personally a
career-changing moment a personal check
person Aleman getting so choked up
because I every time I think of the
interactions that I have with fans and
the korrasami stuff it just what it's
just a beautiful experience and and I
just have not seen that anywhere else to
the same depth and and breadth that Mike
and Brian brought to Legend of Korra
Thank You Janet back around the bend a
Decker hate myself it was a it was
honestly and it's an honor to hear you
talk about the show because I agree with
Cora on so many facets I just keep going
back to that sort of all time the
greatest animated series of all time and
I think about Legend of Korra and I
think I wouldn't start a newer fan to
that world with Korra I feel like it you
you get more out of it if you've gone
through the three epic seasons of Avatar
The Last Airbender the finale of which
by the way had the highest ratings of
the entire series it was something that
just built on top of itself so
beautifully and Batman the Animated
Series is great but it has these great
handfuls of episodes I think we should
discount it for its consistency again a
different animation you know a landscape
and they were doing things differently
but not every episode was heart of ice
there were a lot of filler and that
consistency kind of didn't come through
until shows like Avatar The Last
Airbender where the creators Brian and
Mike were able to say we want to do
three seasons and we're done
and finish our story and it was gorgeous
you know finished with saying that as
much as I love The Legend of Korra there
were aspects of the additions to the
world the seven years later that a lot
of people preferred that they stuck
within avatar for example the cool new
sort of technology that was happening in
the world to some took away from the
martial arts aspects of some of the
combat even though there was a bunch of
great combat in Korra again I really
loved Korra but for me avatar the last
airbender is essential viewing and
noting and any animated show ever in my
life has topped the moment in the
episode tales of Ba Sing se where ma KO
sings leaves from the vine leaves from
the vine little soldier boy comes
marching home that wrecks me wrecks me
and things in korra broke me but this
thing wrecks me so i have to give it to
avatar and i hate myself sometimes -
lets go to Dan in the fact so
that's it yes no that was nice we should
have a rule moving forward and movie
fights that you can't argue your own
against the rules Janet says does she
have argued it even if she wasn't on the
show I believe her
Tricia next time be Batman
so much of it was you know opinion based
there was one thing that I want to point
out regarding Batman in the animated
series which was while Danny Elfman's
theme was used for the series Shirley
Walker largely composed and was and
supervised composition of the original
music for the show itself so it was a
Danny Elfman theme and then a largely
Original Score supervised by Shirley
Walker thank you for that clarification
dan please go ahead and weigh in on this
story I get to go first yeah I mean if
it comes down to passion I can't
everybody I had passion behind their
choices and it was very obvious so it
becomes very hard to differentiate then
it's just differentiating between
opinion at that point I feel like with
Korra and avatar both being on the board
a lot of the discussion became about
Korra versus avatar and avatar versus
Korra and in a weird sneaky way because
so much of the fight for me was directed
at those two against each other
I felt like Trish's argument kind of had
a broader scope and from you know not
just the tone of the show but the
prestige of it it's its legacy and then
I felt like you know and people loved a
lot of things attrition she's still kind
of fought back with Batman and so I feel
like there's so many personal feelings
tied in with Korra and tighten with
avatar and because they're related to
each other and because so much of it was
Hector worrying about stepping on Korra
Minh was London end up standing out for
me strangely so my vote would go to
Trisha all right left the door ajar and
Trisha snuck through
you know I saw it a little bit
differently I thought yeah all the
arguments and Janet just hearing you
talk about the your character your show
and the connection and the impact with
fans like all like the our little
dog-and-pony show here aside that was
lovely and beautiful treatment yeah so
yeah that um yeah that was really
thoughtful and thank you for imparting
that to us overall though I man there
was great arguments Tricia I thought you
laid out it's a wonderful breakdown of
why on many fronts
Batman is a great series but I I felt
like we got some dings in as far as
having just like a treasure trove of
source material and ambience to draw
from to create that world riding the Tim
Burton wave and everything and hearing
uh Janet and Hector go back and forth at
the end of the day I felt Hector laid
the compelling argument as to why Avatar
The Last Airbender was as he said
essential a game changer so impactful
and combined the art and the
storytelling in this unique way so just
by a hair I'm going Hector so we're tied
up one for Trisha one for Hector we're
going to Danielle to give us the
internet poll all right refreshing right
now so you get your hot and fresh
results and we have with 42% of the
audience vote Batman the Animated Series
36% for avatar last airbender 21% for
The Legend of Korra we also had only
they were very passionate about
everything that should have been
included in this yes king of the hill
x-men Steven universe one of my
favorites Rick and Morty The Simpsons
South Park impossible these gargoyles
and a maniacs Full Metal Alchemist
Bojack horseman Clone Wars and someone
who just kept saying duck tales
that's not a bad it's not a bad ball
yeah it's not a bad pick at all and
seasons 1 through 8 of The Simpsons okay
right on yeah yeah I can't argue with
that
yes okay so Tricia takes a commanding 2o
lead Hector and Janet still looking to
get on the board and here's question
number three a new water world a new
Waterworld blu-ray lower story nearly 40
minutes of deleted scenes to the film
hope there's some good Dennis Hopper in
there what famous flop should get the
deluxe special edition treatment next
what famous flop should get the deluxe
special edition treatment next and we're
gonna start with the player number three
Janet least prepared for this so reeling
from the dead last in the show that
means everything to me glad to be here I
said the Adventures of Baron Munchausen
it's a it's I mixed I'm tired there's a
lot of really crazy fun stuff in there
it's one of those I love adventures a
con in a weird way it kind of reminds me
of Goblet of Fire in which which is this
sort of quest idea and and stopping off
and having all of these different
adventures in these different worlds
it's it's wonderfully magical there are
some wonderful performances by actors
that we continue to know and love
through time and and that is something
where you know because there's so much
packed into the movie as it is and I
know that Terry Gilliam shoots way way
way way way way more than ever makes it
into a movie I would love love love to
see all of the pieces that were missing
so I believe that there is easily 40
minutes that would be wonderful and
worth watching I don't know that that's
gonna be true of most quote-unquote
flops like I don't want to see 40 more
minutes of something that I also don't
think is a great movie and usually flops
commonly are so that's mine that's mine
Thank You Janet around the horn to
Hector I brought
little show-and-tell for my thing I want
them to come out with 40 extra minutes
of macGruber I love this movie and in a
lot of comedy circles it is a cult
classic
it's a movie that is super funny it's
funnier in a better movie than it
deserves to be because it was based off
of a ridiculous super short skit on SNL
and the good news is is that macGruber
four years the the folks behind it we're
trying to get a part two made and they
were gonna like crowdfunded they're
gonna do whatever they could to do it
but now there's gonna be a TV show
that's that has been sort of shopped
around by your matekoni from the Lonely
Island who directed it and Will Forte
who stars his macGruber so with the with
the incoming new show which is sort of
macGruber to sequel where picks up after
this one left off I say let's put out
another blu-ray let's put 40 extra
minutes on it cuz I'm about to read the
lackluster bonus features in this here
we go bonus features deleted scene
singular so deleted scene just the one
scene it's got a gag reel shirt and it's
got feature commentary with cast and
crew and I do believe that this movie
for fans of the film would love an extra
40 minutes of adding to the bits adding
to the scenes adding to the jokes doing
alternate jokes doing jokes that they
were afraid they were gonna get an nc-17
because of some of the ridiculous they
were writing this at the same time as
doing SNL and they had no sleep and it's
so off the wall it has such an
unpredictable script so my pick would be
macGruber a new show coming out put out
a put on a complete set also give me the
sketches from SNL all right Thank You
Hector around to Trisha okay and I think
a lot of people are gonna be surprised
and may not know that this was a
Hollywood flop but I'm going with 1999's
Fight Club Dave my first high club so
this was a huge flop at the box office
it was based on a big hit novel given
the major studio treatment had all these
a lists actors in their prime they spent
around 63 million dollars to make this
film and it only made 37 million so it
definitely did not do what they were
expecting it to do and David Fincher is
so smart we when it comes to things like
the copyright claim in the beginning a
lot of people don't know there's like a
split second warning
right after that that's an entirely
separate copyright claim the film itself
the storytelling is so original the
acting and the performances are just
spectacular and I think that if someone
were to find 40 minutes of deleted
scenes that were not included and that
no one had ever seen when it comes to
Fight Club I think that's the deluxe
special edition that the world needs
fight it out y'all my movies an hour in
39 minutes our 39 minutes The Adventures
of Baron Munchhausen running time is 126
minutes that's 2 hours in 6 minutes in
Fight Club is a whopping 2 hours and 31
minutes and if we added an extra 40
minutes on to that hi that would be that
would take a real long time in Fight
Club you were mentioning making 63
million domestically made a hundred
million worldwide on that budget of of
about 63 million oh you said it made
30-something thirdly it made a hundred
million dollars worldwide and even
though didn't make money yet the DVD the
blu-ray is so good and so beloved they
put out a a double a two-disc Edition
DVD in 2001 it was ranked as some of the
best special features best DVD when they
put out the blu-ray and it went out of
print the the fans demanded it that
would they release it and then they did
the blu-ray edition opens with a menu
screen for the romantic comedies never
been kissed on Drew Barrymore and David
Fincher got your very Mohr's permission
to do that so it just has this awesome
blu-ray and DVD that eventually made
them 55 million dollars in video and DVD
rentals so taking all that into account
the movie ended up actually making the
studio 10 million dollars profit because
it did so well and it's such a
jam-packed robust you know home release
The Adventures of Baron Munchausen also
came out with a blu-ray in 2008 that had
like storyboard sequences deleted scenes
plural a three-part documentary making
of the movie and I'm sure that an extra
40 minutes would be fantastic but you
all have already got spent it this is
like this is nothing this is bare-bones
so I say silly you said this was an hour
and a half long yeah it's an hour and 39
minute long SNL sketch oh yeah because
it's not just that it also rips a 90s
action the macGruber
originally were 30 seconds to a minute
and half long I agree with you is super
funny and while there are very funny
moments in macGruber overall I don't
know that anyone needs more scenes in
that movie I think that movie would
benefit from being more in an SNL sketch
form correct me if I'm wrong
feel free to Jerry I just I feel like
it's a bit uninspired action some of the
comedy is awkwardly offensive and I
don't think I'm allowed to laugh at that
kind of way I'm not sure if I and so in
those moments some audience members and
I would venture to say especially with
our political climate right now probably
about half of our nation would not feel
comfortable laughing at moments in that
movie so I just I think that there's a
lot of things than that but I don't know
that that's the extra 40 minutes of
scene that the world needs right now and
you talked about how Fight Club
developed this cult following after the
fact I think you can say the same for a
lot of the films that we're discussing
here but at the theaters itself it was
bested by such hits as Anna and the King
message in a bottle
Bicentennial man The Bone Collector Blue
Streak deuce Bigalow male gigolo the
haunting the generals daughter all of
these movies beat it at the box office
so definitely still in financial flop
territory there and I'd love to hear a
little bit more about what you'd like to
see from a baron von Munchausen good
luck to see 40 minutes of Fight Club as
the extra Baron Munchausen I just didn't
think of Fight Club as a flop but I've
been completely won over and convinced I
do want to see those extra 40 minutes I
know it's a very long movie but I do
think that David Fincher is doing really
interesting work he continues to do
interesting work and I think there
probably are some really interesting
unshot scenes I really Baron Munchausen
[ __ ]
and I am going to get to sit down and
relax while you guys do the speed round
anyway I just like throw ya why do you
like throw it away no but anyway back to
Fight Club that's a great choice that's
what everyone should choose hell that's
what you can stand there time okay I
feel like enough to go around get the
the final thoughts here dad let's go to
the fact zone yeah it's weird because I
this is this came up in the it's it's
sort of new information but it also came
up in the context of what was being
brought up for the rest of the fight
yeah I think it's gonna have to be like
a hybrid of informational for like
information and kind of howling because
I gotta be honest I did not expect a
resignation my whole thinking and disc
you yeah but that unrated blu-ray that
Hector has is five minutes longer and
already has five minutes of extra
material and added scenes the Unrated
version I got four minutes here to the
rated version is on one hour is 34
minutes according to this it's not even
an hour 39 the Unrated is an hour 35
according to the back of this Universal
blu-ray that's four minutes one Julian
on that okay yeah but at the same time
Fight Club it's been released several
other times but I'm really in a quandary
yeah between the two I guess the more
interesting material for me I I think
Tricia brought up a good point of like
and I like macGruber but I have to take
my personal likes out of it and yeah the
idea that it was already a sketch that
was extended from 30 seconds to an hour
and a half and do you want to see 40
more minutes to that race David Fincher
and fight clubs really interesting movie
it was made made 100 million dollars
worldwide would make 37 million dollars
and did have a budget of over sixty
million dollars so financially at least
on its release which generally we define
flop as a movie that was not financially
successful in theaters it was not a
success
I'd have to go Trisha but it's very this
is a very weird round for me too yeah
for sure for sure I hear yeah yeah this
yeah this was a weird one
I felt Hector had like landed some some
pretty devastating blows when he talked
about the special editions of Fight Club
and Baron von Munchausen I think there's
a volunteers there on a Baron
Munchhausen I just like I like throw von
in every name
hector von navarro but yeah at the end
of the day I felt as a fan of this film
Hector being a fan of this film it had
the least additional aspects to it and
it was definitely a flop so I thought
the combination of those things you
swayed me on that so it's one for Tricia
one for Hector Danielle where we at
alrighty going back do it another
refresh get the get the pulls nice and
fresh and hot so we have with 45% of the
audience vote Fight Club 28% for
Adventures of Baron Munchhausen and 25%
for macGruber I mean there were a lot of
other ones that were mentioned I don't
feel you all know it was most of the
Snider cut everyone safe tonight Reds
Metacritic Rick Snyder but we all knew
that was gonna happen you want the thing
that you want and I hope that you get it
there was one comment that I really
liked I know a lot of you guys will pull
out the room to be funny but it's pas
little on Twitter said the room with
directors commentary about Tommy Wiseau
and the deleted Chris our subplot that
sounds delight I want that as well yeah
I would watch that
oh that sounds awkwardly delightful room
doubt couldn't do it
after the disaster on it sounds like I'm
good okay so it's crazy times here are
movie fights because Tricia Clean Sweep
300 in the first three rounds that means
first for me for sure well played well
played but now we must determine who
will move on to the speed round to face
Tricia so Janet Hector this time yes you
stop trying didn't get a point Hector
try really hard and did you get a point
good company no no you both owe me you
both argued wonderfully and it's these
have been tough fights to call but now
it comes down to a time right to see who
will face Trisha in the speed round here
we go
um so how this works I'm gonna ask a
question shout out your answer the first
person to answer first will have 20
seconds to elaborate and tell us why
they had the better answer then the
other player will get 20 seconds and
then back around 10 second rebuttal 10
second rebuttal
these are going to be movie options
right I'm gonna ask a Legend of Korra
for everyone okay probably not
applicable your view will paint yourself
into a corner alright alright makes
sense everybody so shout out your aunt
shout out your answer okay and then
you'll get the first person answer will
get 20 seconds then 20 seconds and then
10 second rebuttals here's the question
rebel Wilson is getting rave reviews for
performance in isn't it romantic what
actor who has never done one should star
in a romantic comedy Jackie Chan has he
never done okay we have Jackie Chan
Janet
well oh I'm still supposed to shout so I
thought okay got it yes actor who's
never done a romantic combination
oh gosh I don't know this is all so new
to me
processing Oh shouting out I'm rocking
my brain to think of somebody that I
like that hasn't been in a romantic
comedy I can't guarantee that anybody I
would say has not been in a romantic
comedy okay thank you for taking us in
your thought process I've been I'm I'm I
love the show counterpart and I love
what Jake Hayes is doing with those two
roles i'ma go ahead and say JK Simmons
romantic comedy okay
sneaky Legend of Korra all right
so we have Jackie Chan we've JK Simmons
20 seconds on the clock for Hector
20 seconds begin as soon as you start
talking my argument is Jackie Chan
because I love him everyone loves him
and Jackie Chan I think on a recent
appearance like maybe a few years back
on Conan said he keeps getting cast in
these action movies and all he's ever
wanted to do is be like in a romantic
comedy and nobody's ever let him do that
and that broke my heart when I heard
that and and Conan was like you think
you could be good he's like yes and he
was doing a little bit like rom-com bits
thank you all right 20 seconds for Janet
it starts whenever you start speaking to
be honest with you I sort of feel like
the Shanghai Knights Shanghai de
Shanghai noon and the rush hour rush
hours are romantic comedies in their own
special way so I feel like we've seen
that the touching sweet version of
Jackie Chan we get to see that every
time he does an action film JK is keeps
being lauded over and over for his
snarky characters time and you know the
rest 10 second rebuttals JK Simmons I
don't know it's just not my tempo I
don't know no I love him he would be
great he would be great oh [ __ ] Janet 10
second rebuttal Jackie Chan's Jackie
Chan's great I feel like I know what
that movie looks like I'm feel like I've
already seen it even though it may not
exist he's adorable
but you know I just help each other
oh yeah sorry Dan yeah
[Laughter]
yeah Hector you sacrifice your speed
blast joke largely because of that I and
because I thought she you know what I
mean
those are technically buddy comedies but
I thought you made a good point that he
did not rebut about seeing that food for
Jackie Chan so yeah you get it from me
Janet I go with Janet on this one
Danielle I have to go by this round by
this round the one that quit and gave up
and then did not stay and argued their
choice was Hector so I'm sorry yeah
Janet you are I am completely
intimidated by both of you I was so
excited to walk away and just watch as a
fan and be like they're both amazing
tough sorry you're gonna keep fighting
right you know because you may not
believe this but you made me argue
against someone else related to the
legend of korra and that that was it
that was the best technique yeah I
couldn't come be like oh the voice of
Tenzin I can't you did a great job all
day except for that rebuttal I agree bad
okay
otherwise awesome otherwise yeah
listen I've sacrificed a lot of things
in my life to make one joke so I've
sacrificed so much for the bit okay
so that did not count for a point it is
still three nil Trisha so Janet you need
a clean sweep it is game point all night
long for Trisha okay it is game point
pleasure to lose to you my friend please
don't be intimidated the speed round is
where I learn to use my gas it works the
exact same way as the tiebreaker did all
ask the question call out your answer
and then 20 seconds 20 seconds 10 second
rebuttal 10 second rebuttal
let's jump into the fun what location
from any movie would be the best place
to go on a romantic Valentine's date the
Shire we heard the shire Trisha
five diagonally diagonally okay Diagon
Alley and the Shire we heard the Shire
from Janet first twenty seconds begin
when you speak uh well first of all it's
a real place so you can actually go
there no offense
I mean Diagon Alley is but it's not it's
a there's a different level of tourist
attraction that we're talking about here
I think if you go to the Diagon Alley
you kind of wish that you really were at
the real Diagon Alley and it's not close
enough all due respect to what Universal
has done but when you go to the Shire
you feel like you're in the Shire you're
surrounded by all the hot I'm okay
Trisha Diagon Alley has amazing things
you could do that are date things you
can go get a chocolate frog you can go
get a butterbeer you can go
window-shopping through lots of magical
mystical things if we're talking about
the Shire that means we're talking about
middle-earth and middle-earth is goddamn
terrifying Hobbiton the set for the
Shire is a wonderful place that you can
go visit but the actual Shire itself
time ten second rebuttal Janet Hobbiton
in the Shire for me are one of the same
I did think about an actual real place
that I'd been that was absolutely
charming magical made me feel like I was
transported into another place if I have
the opportunity to have that for reals
the actual Shire Nazgul come there you
are not safe in the actual Shire and if
you leave your house for a while all
your neighbors come and take your stuff
look what happen to war bill oh that is
not a nice place to go on it time all
right Dan Merle oh thank you
longtime viewers of the show know that I
would have said the Chocolate Factory
from Willy Wonka and lost
I probably weighed that I mean listen
yeah I thought so too but it was
apparently wrong
I feel like um I feel like I had a
better idea of what the date was gonna
be a window shopping and chocolate frog
eating from Diagon Alley so I'm that
that's where my vote would go all right
that's one for Tricia and Diagon Alley
and the Potter verse Danielle um you
know I as much as I did appreciate you
in its argument about you know the Shire
and how magical it is I agree with Dan I
did feel like I had more of an idea
about what this date would be and then
also I forgot about them little stealin
hobbits
yeah I don't want to go somewhere where
I'm gonna get mugged
okay I'm square for that that's cool so
I'm also gonna go with Trisha
Hershberger you are you've actually been
Hobbiton yes yes it is a beautiful view
I went there on my honeymoon so like the
ultimate date so I was like how do I
arguably would go to Diagon Alley
and tourism commercial yeah Trisha um
you came in you yeah on these phones
nicely done thank you and so unexpected
because this was such a tough fight
today oh my gosh yeah absolutely
please go ahead and tell us what you got
coming up give us some shoutouts
anything at all sure um I currently
hosts two tech shows one for Kingston
Technology that's kind of like a tech
made easy' show and one for Newegg
that's a live show every Thursday and
then I host a video game show for a geek
and sundry and you can often find me
playing around over at Nerdist as well
so that's where you can find me online
plus at fat-girl Trish with no eye on
the girl on all the social stuff super
cool Trisha well fought today just
devastating
Janet you were like showing off all I'm
having notes on this card but then you
just came in with gems and these
thoughts that were like that it's all my
hat you guys because I didn't have any I
didn't know I should be box-office no
each man came in with just these
emotional things because you picked the
legend oh yeah second not on that one
not on that round well you were awesome
and he's just it was just fun to hear
you and you had and you had some
wonderful points please tell us how even
find your show and plug anything you are
you can get you can certainly get which
the stars you should subscribe it's
available anywhere you get your podcasts
I have my own podcasts on the maps fun
that we're called the JV Club I
interview women except for during the
summer interview dudes very sure Trisha
that I will be having you on my show
very soon oh very much like to talk
about awkward teenage years with you
because that is the focal point of my
podcast Oh JV Club
that was very podcast heavy but you can
follow me at Janet Varney on Twitter the
JV Club on Instagram and that's it thank
you so much awesome having you Hector
you fought valiantly you know that uh
forget about that one review
you were great I love listening to you
talk about nerd stuff man we and
hard-and-fast my favorite thing I've
ever done in my life was what I did it I
picked it I don't know where man yeah it
was great yeah please go ahead and shout
out okay go get the Legend of Korra on
blu-ray because it's such a good show
if you and then also get the Avatar The
Last Airbender which also was recently
put out on the legend of course so great
go get the comic books they're fantastic
there's gonna be new ones coming out
this year they're finishing out one of
their newer trilogy I was amazing and
you can follow me online at Hector's
funny and check out my movie podcast
which is called the 500 greatest films
podcast you can find it at 500 GF
podcast where me and my buddy are gonna
take ten years to watch 500 movies we
watch one a week why the journey we've
seen some sneakers and thinkers and good
your episodes coming out on Monday cuz
we just watched hairspray the original
hairspray og hairspray yes the John
Waters yes yes yes the knowledgeable and
so that episode's dropping on Monday
a.m. and Danielle is on it and she's
phenomenal so check that out she's
always foot on yeah and let's go over to
the Dan Kim Dan Merle thank you so much
rolling down the fact zone and he's any
thoughts you'd like to previous with
happy February 14th to everyone yes out
there I hope you have wait that's not
what the greeting card companies calling
it that's what I call it yeah however
you choose to celebrate it there's no
right way or wrong way don't let anyone
guilt you into doing something you don't
want to do enjoy the day nice Dan thank
you for that because I oh I've been I've
been a sad boy on Valentine's Day before
so sometimes need to hear that thanks
bro time hell yeah thank you sir Karen
right it gets a fast-food go see a bad
movie yeah
Oh Daniel Radford thank you so much for
being our social chair and just a friend
to the Internet's oh thank you thank you
very much thank you Dan for that
encouraging statement I'm gonna be out
with my boyfriend having a date we're
doing small stuff at home for watching
bad movies on Saturday yeah it's fun I'd
rather do that stay in make I know how
to make me I'm sitting there Radford on
Instagram with Danielle underscore
Bradford again I do have a patreon where
we do talk about things like bad movies
and we hang out and it would be really
fun for you to join us there I am also
on a podcast on the max fun network
called tights and fights where you talk
about wrestling we just uploaded one
today we do it every Thursday and I will
see you guys there okay I love you and
everyone loves you too Tanya and yeah
please follow me
Hal Rudnick on Twitter and Instagram
will talk about movies and we'll talk
about a lot of dumb [ __ ] and our nation
hoot-hoot and if you are in LA on
Saturday night the 16th of February come
to the Upright Citizens Brigade Theatre
on Franklin for the tournament of nerds
this Saturday gonna be super fun and
otherwise yeah I want to thank everybody
I want to thank Billy bids I wanna thank
jte and I want to thank you again for
watch and see you next time bye